let's say that you have two folks that
are trying to collectively push a box
across the snow
towards a target so this is where the
box is right over here
and this is the target right over here
let me write that that is the target
that's where they're trying to get the
box
and person a
personally because they can't for some
reason they can't push it exactly from
behind the box maybe there's not a good
footing there or i guess if they press
there maybe the box squeezes a little
bit
so person a has to push in a direction
that's not exactly going in the
direction of the target so they push in
a direction
that looks like this and so let me show
you there this this vector i'm drawing
essentially represents the force that
they're exerting this is their force
vector this is person a's force vector
so this is
person a's force vector and we know that
the length of this vector or another way
to think about it the magnitude
of vector a is 330 newtons
330 newtons and let's say person b once
again because they can't they can't
they can't push exactly in the direction
of the target maybe the box is really
soft right over here
person b
is pushing at this angle person b is
pushing at this angle
right over here
so that right over there that vector is
the force that person b is
is pushing onto it in the direction
and there the magnitude of that force of
that vector of person b's pushing
is 300 newtons
and we know their angles that those make
with the direction of the target
so if this is
the direction of the target right over
here
we know that this is a 35 degree angle
35 degree angle and we know that this is
a
this is a 15 degree angle
now what i want you to do is pause this
video
and think about how much of each of
their force is going in the direction of
getting the box towards the target and
then who is actually exerting more force
in that direction we see that person a
is exerting a total
a higher magnitude of force in this
direction than person b is doing in that
direction 330 newtons versus 300 but
who's helping the box go more in that
direction and by how much more and also
what's the total force now pushing the
box in that direction
so i'm assuming you've had a goa go at
it and the key here is to find the
component of each of these vectors the
magnitude of of each of these vectors in
this direction in the direction towards
the target
and so let's look first at let's look
first at vector a so vector a looks like
this and i'll just draw them separately
just so we can
clean it up a little bit vector a looks
like this we know it's magnitude the
magnitude of vector a is equal to 330
newtons
and
if we say that the target is in this
direction right over here
so that's the target is someplace out
here we've already been told that this
is 35 degrees
so what we really what we really want to
do is find
the component
the the magnitude
of the component going in that direction
right over there
and the way we can do that is just with
our traditional trig functions this
right over here is a right triangle
we are looking for this side right over
here we have let me just call that let
me just call that a
sub x
and we already know that the magnitude
of a is 330 newtons
so the magnitude let me just say that
the mag let me just write it this way
just so we don't confuse so let's just
say the magnitude of the vector in the
in the x direction so this vector right
over here we could write like this the
magnitude of that we'll just write it
without the vector notation
so how can we think about that well we
know cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
so we could write cosine
cosine
of 35 degrees is equal to the length of
the adjacent side that would just be a
sub x without the vector over it we're
just saying that that's the magnitude of
vector a sub x
over the magnitude of vector a
over 330 newtons
over
300 330 newtons or we could say that a
sub x is equal to 330
330 times the cosine of 35 degrees
and we can make the exact same argument
for b
vector b
so let me draw it like this
you could maybe i'll draw it like this
just to make it a little bit
let me do a little bit different
if this is the direction to the target
so once again i'll just draw a
horizontal line for that then relative
to that vector b looks something like
this
it looks something
vector b looks something like
that so that is
vector b
b sub x in the direction of the target
so we would drop a
perpendicular like that this would be
this right over here would be
the vector
b
sub x
and so what is the magnitude of b sub x
going to be equal to and we could say
that the magnitude of b sub x we'll just
call that b sub x without the vector
notation same exact logic this is this
is 15 degrees
cosine of 15 degrees is going to be the
length of the adjacent side over the
length of the hypotenuse we already know
that the length of the hypotenuse is 300
newtons
so we could write
that cosine of 15 degrees is equal to b
sub x length of the adjacent side over
the length of the hypotenuse or that b
sub x is equal to 300 times cosine
of 15
15 degrees so let's get our calculator
out and let's calculate what these
things are
so
let's see
we have
times cosine of 35 degrees
gets us to
270 newtons so that's a sub x is 270
newtons and b sub x is 300 times cosine
of 15 degrees
and we get 289.777
so what we see is even though b's
magnitude is less than a's magnitude the
component of vector b going in the
direction of the target is actually
larger than the component of vector a
going so if we were rounding to the
nearest to the nearest newton if we're
rounding to the nearest newton
this right over here
the magnitude of this vector right over
here
b sub x
that is
200 if we round to the nearest newton
290 newtons
so this is
approximately 290 newtons length or i
guess you say magnitude while this one
this one is a little bit shorter
it's a little bit shorter we saw if we
round to the nearest newton it's about
270 newtons the length of this one
the length of this one is 270 newtons
approximately
so if you were to say how much more is
person b pushing in the direction that
we care about it's about well if we want
to be a little more precise we can
subtract the two so we could take
cosine
of 15
minus 330
cosine
of 35
and we get
about 19 and a half newton's difference
that the blue person b is contributing
19 and a half 19.458
newtons more in that direction towards
the target than person a is but if we
wanted to talk about what is the total
what is the total force going in that
direction then we would take the sum of
these two things
so we would
the total force in that direction
is going to be
560 newtons if we round to the nearest
newton so if you add this blue component
to this magenta component you get this
one
right over here
which is
560 newtons so this whole vector right
over here
its magnitude
its magnitude so i could write that as
the i could write that as the magnitude
of
a sub x
plus
b sub x
which is the same thing as
a sub x plus b sub x i already said
these are the equivalent of the
magnitude of each of these vectors is
equal to
i could write approximately equal to
newtons